Katy Perry reveals why she finally told
the truth about Taylor Swift she started
it and it's time for her to finish it in
a new issue of NME the swish-swish
singer explains why she finally decided
to address her feud with a pop star
during a May appearance on The Late Late
Show quote I wish that I could turn the
other cheek
every single time but I'm also not a
pushover you know especially when
someone tries to assassinate my
character
[Music]
in a 2014 interview with Rolling Stone
Taylor claimed that a former friend
stole some of her backup dancers and
quote basically tried to sabotage an
entire arena tour while the 27 year old
never dropped Katie's name rumors
swirled that the singers diss track bad
blood was inspired by the beef during
her appearance on the late-night show
Katie confirmed that three of her
dancers left tea Swift's tour to join
her prism world tour I tried to talk to
her about it and she she wouldn't speak
to you it was a full shutdown and then
she writes a song about me and I'm like
okay cool cool cool that's how you want
to do with it
karma the roar singer says she finally
reached a breaking point with the
popstar quote no one has asked me about
my side of the story and there are three
sides of every story one two and the
truth
you